in this video we're going to play a game
that I like to call
what is the better deal
so let's look at an example let's say
there's a 16 ounce bottle of shampoo
that costs four dollars and let's say
there's another bottle of that shampoo
on the right next to it on the store
shelf it's the same brand same shampoo
just a different size it's 35 ounces and
it costs seven dollars pause this video
and think about which is the better deal
so there's several ways of approaching
this you might see that wow 35 ounces is
more more than double 16 ounces and the
price isn't more than double four
dollars so this is probably the better
deal
but just in case it doesn't jump out at
you that way you could think about
something known as unit pricing or unit
costs and the way we could do that is we
could take the price let's say in this
top example
the bottle costs four dollars and then
we'll divide it by the number of ounces
we have divided by 16 ounces you might
recognize that this is going to be 25
cents an ounce you might be able to do
that math in your head or you could put
punch that into a calculator 25 cents
per
ounce
the other situation right over here if
we took 35 or we took seven dollars I
should say
seven dollars divided by 35 ounces
if you do the math there that is going
to be 20 cents 20 cents per ounce and so
here you're able to make an apples to
applicable apples comparison you know
where you're paying more or less per
ounce and we can see that our our
initial intuition our initial gut was
right that the larger bottle here is
indeed cheaper and that's why you see
sometimes people like to buy the larger
sizes sometimes they'll buy in bulk
because it's often the case that the
larger sizes you get it cheaper per unit
per ounce per use per square foot
whatever we're talking about now it is
good to verify I have sometimes been in
the store where the bulk pricing
actually is not cheaper than the less
bulk pricing so always try to do the
math maybe you walk around with a
calculator or it turns out in many
stores they do the unit pricing for you
so this is an example of a price that or
something that you might see for the
price at a store and this looks like
it's some kind of I don't know toilet
paper or something it says six rolls of
ultra Comfort Care something or another
and the price here is eight dollars and
49 cents but they give us the unit
pricing it's right over here they're
saying five dollars and two cents per
square foot so if there was another
different size of this exact same toilet
paper you could compare it on a per
square foot basis to figure out which is
cheaper or maybe there's two brands that
also are coming in different sizes you
can compare which is cheaper by looking
at the per square feet it'd be more
grammatically correct to say per square
foot but I think you get the idea and
it's not always going to be per square
foot it might be per ounce it might be
per use but the important thing is that
you're comparing the same units to
figure out which one is the better deal